ça s'arrête là en novembre je suis une
avance innovant la diffusion à la
diffusion est ce que les derniers
épisodes ont déjà été tournés ou pas du
tout non on les interviews 9 à septembre
c'est quoi un peu l'ambiance en ce
moment alors en ce moment je tourne pas
vous non mais vous vous êtes fait les 18
16 euros et donc vous avez tout prix
mais je reviens j'arrive d'accord et je
vais dire vous allez dire au revoir mais
c'est quoi l'ambiance et et toi tu es
depuis un an à peu près ouais bah de
bolton sur la fin mais j'ai lu
la saga d'été le prime
connaissez bien de son temps
je reconnais que je regardais le
plus beau c'est ça la
tumeur et ça anthony a été au coeur
d'une intrigue sa seule scène voilà
simon dont je posais la question est-ce
que c'est pas un peu triste la fin en
tous les cas là la fin les derniers
épisodes de tourner si c'est triste mais
c'est bien sur le plateau de plutôt
bonne parce que parce qu'on est content
de terminer on n'est pas content de
terminer mais on a envie de terminer ça
plutôt en beauté et puis de profiter
chacun des dessins des autres et de
l'équipe vous aviez marre après 18 ans
ont pas du tout mais pas du tout mais
moi tu as un personnage un peu
particulier serre que j'ai du mal à en
avoir marre parce qu'elle est mon
personnage est bipolaire et
voilà c'est dit raymond est un peu
particulière donc je me suis jamais
ennuyé ouais mais maintenant je suis je
suis très triste quand même que ça
s'arrête rien qu'on avait bien détester
aussi c'est vous vous êtes un stade est
carrément là bas vous avez acheté une
maison vous avez un canon j'ai un crédit
vendu l'appartement maintenant ça
devient crédit bah oui parce qu'il faut
que je rentre parce qu'il faut que je
scolarise ma fille à paris parce que la
wii je travaille raoui donc en fait je
reviens harris avec de très beaux
projets à paris mais à paris du coup
est-ce que de plus vous êtes déjà
proposé d'autres séries ou pas du tout
d'autres séries non non lâche pas au
théâtre vous partez vers le théâtre si
bien et toi en tenir quant à proposer
d'autres choses du coup d'envoi nous
appartient ou d'autres séries voilà il a
beaucoup c'est serré dans là encore
serré pas encore mais je lâche pour nous
une fiction de science fiction est
pareil du théâtre aussi qui pourrait
arriver prochainement voilà et jean luc
azoulay et vous pourrez vous a déjà une
histoire d'amour bas parce que je
connais ça a coûté la vie en ville ou
pas non non non pour l'instant chez un
autre chose donc voilà
si tu veux j'assiste à saouler 80 euros
tu tournes toute la journée de 8 heures
[Applaudissements]
l'économie est dur et compliqué on parle
en revanche du retour de premiers
baisers est-ce que ça est-ce que ça tu
es retour n'a pas du tout eu j'en ai
entendu parler way est depuis quelques
mois n'ont plus du tout non là il ya eu
un moment donné
voilà on en a discuté mais depuis n'ont
pas de nouvelles il ya beaucoup
d'acteurs et d'actrices
compagne aussi voulu venir parce qu'ils
sont fâchés après la chaîne tout
simplement parce qu'ils ont appris par
la presse et parce qu'il faut parfois
être l agora la presse vous l'avez
appris par la presse a mal à 18 ans oui
mais certains matins vous prenez le
petit déjeuner vous avez ouvert le
journal on s'y attendait on en parle est
vrai qu'il ya eu une grande réunion sur
les plateaux étant donné que j'
marseillaise je pensais que j seraient
conviés je n'y ai pas été conviée
puisqu'ils ont compris que les gens qui
étaient présents et c'est vrai que je
les lui d'un an par la presse mais en
même temps je m'y attendais c'est pas
non plus une nouvelle je vais
quand même prendre imany même donc on
s'y attendait faut être honnête parce
que la chaîne passe un moment pour l'
annonce et puis comme nous le boulot
c'est de le dire de le savoir à l'avancé
en devance l'appel mais si mal à la fois
alors la chaîne la vraie raison de
l'arrêt la présidence et parce que
d'abord il développe d'autres projets
avec marseille avec la région
marseillaise j'ai clairement des accords
commerciaux et que donc ils ont envie de
faire d'autres fictions et qui sentait
la série n'est quand même pas celle de 6
millions 800 mille 0,6 oui mais pas les
deux millions cinq cent mille est l'une
des plus forte concurrence et d une
fiction comme scènes de ménage qui fait
1 millions de plus donc un vrai
phénomène d'usure est néanmoins il
sentait qu'il y avait encore quelque
chose et aller l'affection des gens il
ya un double alors vous savez que l'ipad
c'est ma mort et la personne qui m'a dit
ça irait extrêmement bien la série
pourrait ou en tout cas sera en
discussion pour renaître sur amazon et
ben voilà la bonne nouvelle
si c'est leur tête le groupe tf1 est pas
une bonne nouvelle vous reviendrez pas
mais je sais pas faim c'est un lien
moment donné ou
pour vous c'est un signe les choses
s'arrêtent aussi si vous retournez à
paris en plus c'est que vous avez des
projets théâtrale et tout c'est
peut-être tout layton et a trop
non je sais pas là pour moi c'est un peu
je sais qu'il faut que je tourne
jusqu'en septembre je finirai jusqu'à
fin septembre d'accord mais c'est oui
c'est peut-être une nouvelle page et
puis voilà il ya des choses dans la vie
il ya des signes peut-être que s'il faut
que ça s'arrête en tout cas ils
détruisent pas le décor parce qu'on en
oublie quand même qu à 1100 mètres
carrés ont été construites saisir ivan
le terrible
bref dire la vraie bref a vu que la
lutte oui les épisodes tout alors il a
un petit peu il il est chez lui sort pas
combien pour ce qui est ou pas l'eau et
il a tout vu au début j'étais très jeune
donc je sais pas s'il a toujours assisté
au début c'était que dans des studios en
fait où il y avait le mistral tout ça et
puis après c'est peillon en extérieur
pour ils ont tourné ils ont commencé au
parc borély après ils ont fait la belle
de mai
le panier etc et voilà il
c'est gênant d'avoir faire d'un plateau
ouais
j'ai passé cinq ans à télé star où j'ai
un petit peu embêté pendant 5 toute la
production de plus belle la vie les
auteurs les comédiens etc c'est vrai
vous trouver des infos donc je pense que
je suis un petit peu persona non grata à
plus belle la vie mais mais c'est gentil
mais comptait inviter mes yeux après
voilà plus belle la vie c'est quand même
un monument du paysage et devises et
audiovisuelle en c est vraiment le 18
novembre 2022 ça va ça va resté vraiment
comme eto'o anthony le fait d'avoir été
dense d'abord dans une série aussi culte
tu as fait des séries cultes tels que
tata fait navarro taper on a beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de séries très très
con les années fut marquée tourné
ensemble dans les années sourit on a
tourné aussi d'abaisser sa kibboutz
d'acteurs ici c'est formidable
pardon si je
n'arrive et quitter ce petit on sait que
je suis monté combien 85 fois sur scène
oui mais dans une sextape
367 je chantais
looking
in person nes en sortant des sardines
mais ça reste quand même artistique ces
personnes c'est de la scène absolument
alors il ya laurent kerriou c'est
connais bien je connais
tu
regardes
tous vos messages
d'encouragement et d'affection moi je
vais vous dire juste un petit mot c'est
que ayons la fierté grâce à vous grâce à
nous aussi un petit peu c'est qu'on est
la plus belle histoire
de la télévision en france voilà dix
huit ans de bonheur grâce à vous comme
j'ai dit hier nous nous étions sur le
plateau mais vous vous étiez derrière
vos écrans et sa personne pour un autre
nous l'enlever voie la plus belle la vie
c'est vous c'est nous et
et c'était très très très beau je vous
aime tellement vraiment ça y est les
larves pas bien sale orange ce qui était
promis de pas pleurer voilà je vous
embrasse très fort je vous aime
[Applaudissements]
les choses ça me revient sur tf1 c'est
en discussion avec amazon et le 18
novembre l'épisode final ça sera un
prime qui sera diffusée en face de la
star ac de la star ac ok c'est sympa ça
va être compliqué
je lui annonce aux djs cocktail est
encore un peu avec laurent qu'est
vraiment un bon ami à moi et qui est
très touchée on est un peu déçu de
pleureuses de deux heures non mais c'est
vrai on est les plus émotifs c'est vrai
que
ça me fait de la peine de le voir alors
en mairie saphir de laurent gardées à
celui qui tournait le plus simple était
la csbc 18 ans d'une vie vous j'imagine
que à marseille vous êtes une star pas
cessé vous êtes zidane ah non
je suis dit dan j'ai jamais vu le truc
comme ça à marseille
j'imaginais dix inédits et zidane en
même temps moi tu as vécu du coup aussi
à marseille là pendant tout ce temps-là
tu faisais des crises et leur tour
faisait des allers-retours huawei et
wallace et rita marquer quand même
vraiment ou pas du oui oui parce que le
rôle est extraordinaire le rôle est
extraordinaire et pareil si des basques
et si vous n'avez pas vu mais il était
alors jeté henry mais cette année je me
suis préparé l'émission il est habillé
en bouc
la bête ouais voilà donc j'arrive mais
grisant parce que détériorer
s'y attendait dire
est ce que ça vous a plu le moment où la
série parce que certains disent que
c'est à ce moment là que la série s'est
abîmé et d'autres au contraire qu'elle a
progressé le moment où la série a
commencé à coller à l'actualité il ya eu
toute cette scène avec un plan à trois
qui a collé un peu il ya eu enfin il ya
il ya eu des séries d homophobes il ya
eu oui j'étais la première la première
protagonistes féminines homosexuels dans
une série française il ya eu plein de
trucs mais en même temps nous on a
toujours collé à l'actualité depuis le
début c'est en fait c'est ça qu'il faut
c'est je pense la toux de plus belle la
vie voilà et c'est quand on a commencé à
ne plus coller à l'actualité que ça a
commencé à être un problème croyez vous
avec le plan à trois sur des personnes
un peu âgé ça a cartonné bah ouais ah
oui est-ce que c'était paul s'était
toujours expliqué
ils faisaient ça les personnes d'âge et
oui ça me coûte non
un tout petit un tout petit détail c'est
que l'a fort justement il a raison
laurent la force de l'émission c'est
qu'elle devait toujours coïncidé avec
l'actualité or c'est écrit un mois al
avance donc il fallait que ça coïncide
avec l'actualité du monde la discussion
là pour ça qu'on demande des élections
il tournait 2 s'incline 5 par exemple il
y avait ces vilaines royal et sarko et
une facile ça avait été l'inversé
à ce sujet d'ailleurs ségolène et
nicolas sarkozy il avait tourné deux
séquences sait sauf qu'au dernier moment
françois bayrou montée est normal et son
âge et ils ont commencé à paniquer en se
disant qu'est ce qu'on fait si françois
bayrou est aussi absolument égal la
présidentielle vous fournit des on est
on ne peut plus rien faire et du coup on
n'a pas la séquence au moment où vous
confirmez je comprends pas ce
que c'était
garçon tout ça c'est à dire que cesse et
c'est une journée une on parla plus de
temps à moi en plus j'ai eu la chance de
tourner que dans des décors extérieurs
siens que j'ai jamais tourné dans leur
accord le mistral est un moment on avait
tué ce que vous avez rencontré l'amour
dans la série oui oui au début oui serge
dupire devrait pas vous mais vous avez
ça on va te parler vous traverserez non
c'est pas mon mari mais j'ai eu une
histoire avec serge dupire qui jouent et
le compagnon de céline frémont et on
aimerait savoir angle quelques temps
il ya quinze ans et je sais bien se
goupiller tueur sur les histoires bon ma
pauvre dame est et vous mets toi ben moi
pas facile j avais un renard mort des
blessures c'est pas facile
alors j'aimerais quand même qu'on parle
de vous parce que haddad déjà je veux
dire je sais je sais bien que je juge
dit promo propos de rebecca vous êtes en
tournée à la rentrée de septembre dans
la pièce pour le meilleur et pour le
pire avec booder janvier ce qui le fait
comment réduire
[Applaudissements]
poignées fiction c'est pour les très
ambitieux c'est un projet de section
effectivement c'est ça c'est vous qui le
faites oui d'accord voilà moi je suis
comédien et on reproduit ça avec un
réalisateur et une équipe de
réalisateurs qui fait les les effets
spéciaux c'est la première fois que je
fais un truc de science fiction donc on
s'éclate
deuxième projet on me dit si oui c'est
quoi ça cccd sache que je vais organiser
l'été prochain mais non c'est j'ai un
ami qui est un domaine à miramont de
guyenne et qui accueille des jeunes
miramont de guyenne ouais bah voilà en
faire quoi le domaine du saut du loup
voilée way pour faire des stages
justement qui vont combiner un peu le
l'acting et le sport je pense que c'est
pour un tracteur est bon
pour être bien dans sa tête pour être
bien dans sa tête et un peu de
discipline c'est à dire que
[Applaudissements]